[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: In this
quickstart, we'll
install the Google Cloud
SDK, initialize it,
and run core G Cloud commands
from the command line.
Before you begin, make sure you
have a Google Cloud Platform
project you can use
and that you have
Python and the Google Cloud
SDK installed on your system.
Begin by using the gcloud init
command to set up the SDK.
This will prompt you to
log in, and after, will
open a web browser for you
to do so if you choose y.
Log into your
Google user account
by following the
onscreen prompts
to grant permission access
to Google Cloud resources.
Back in the command line,
select a cloud platform project
to use.
And if you have the Google
Compute Engine API enabled,
you can choose a default
Compute Engine zone.
After running these
steps, gcloud init
confirms that you have
successfully completed
the necessary set of steps.
To view information about
your SDK installation,
run the following command.
Use gcloud auth list to display
accounts whose credentials
are stored locally.
Use gcloud config list
to see the properties
of your active SDK config.
Use gcloud info to view
a summary of details
about your Cloud
SDK installation,
including installed SDK
components, the active user
account and more.
Finally, you can use gcloud
help to view information
about gcloud commands
and other topics.
[MUSIC PLAYING]